y gráficas 0.04 en la recta numérica
tenemos aquí esta recta numérica que va
desde 0 a 0.1 o lo que es lo mismo una
décima y entre 0 y una décima tenemos
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez espacios iguales es
decir cada uno de estos espacios mide lo
mismo entonces cada uno de estos
espacios representa una décima parte de
una décima es decir una de diez partes
iguales y bueno puede parecer algo
complicado entonces para entenderlo
mejor veamos cómo se ve una décima parte
de una décima
entonces aquí tenemos
este cuadrado que dividía en 10 partes
iguales como puedes ver son 10 partes
iguales y si yo coloreo el relleno de
color una de estas partes entonces estoy
coloreando una décima parte esta
cantidad es lo que la recta numérica
representa una décima pero después
dividimos esa décima parte en diez
partes iguales entonces observa el
cuadrado grande está formado por diez
partes iguales si dividimos cada una de
esas diez décimas que forman todo el
cuadrado en diez partes iguales
tendremos esto puedes ver que esta fila
de arriba que es lo que representa la
recta numérica que teníamos dividida en
diez partes iguales
esta representa una décima ya está
dividida en diez partes iguales
cada una de estas pequeñas partes
representa una décima de toda la décima
cada uno de estos cuadros pequeños
representa una décima de una décima o lo
que es lo mismo representa una centésima
una décima de una décima es una
centésima porque cuando tú divides una
décima en diez partes iguales obtienes
diez cuadros entonces en total tú tienes
aquí 100 cuadros pequeños así que una
décima de una décima es una centésima
ahora regresando a la recta numérica ya
sabemos que esta distancia una décima de
una décima es una centésima y queremos
graficar 0.04 observa el 4 en qué
posición está este 0 está en las
unidades este 0 está en las décimas y el
4 está en las centésimas
esto es cuatro centésimas en fracción se
representa como cuatro sobre cien cuatro
centésimas por lo tanto si uno de estos
espacios representa una centésima y
queremos cuatro centésimas necesitamos
avanzar en la recta numérica cuatro
espacios así que avanzamos uno dos tres
cuatro aquí está cuatro centésimas o
0.04